hey everyone it's lucy here i know i
haven't posted for a while but it's
intern and grad recruitment season now
so i thought i'd make a video to show
you the intern resume that got me into
amazon web services so for those who are
new to this channel i was an intern at
amazon for around eight months
and now i'm a graduate working full-time
so the reason i decided to make this
video is because some of my friends have
been asking for resume tips on how they
can improve their own resume i'm going
to be showing you my resume
i'm going to be critiquing it telling
you what went well
what could be improved on remember to
give this video a like and subscribe to
this channel to stay updated with tech
career and student advice and yeah let's
just get right into it
alright so this is the resume that i
submitted in march of 2020
and i'm just going to be going through
section by section what i put on this
page
so just remember first of all to keep
your resume to
one page that way it makes it a lot
easier for the recruiter or anyone who's
screening your resume
to skim through it and see what the key
points are
all right so starting off with the first
section you can see that i have my full
name
and key contact details so email mobile
and linkedin
it's pretty standardized and it's what
i've seen across different resume
templates so i won't talk too much about
this but it's just a good way for the
recruiter to know how to contact you if
they're interested in progressing you to
the next round
so the second part that i have is the
education section and in this included
both my uni
and my high school which i'm not too
sure why i would recommend just keeping
your
university on the education section i
have unsw bachelor of computer science
and this was my old degree before i
transferred to a bachelor of information
systems instead i would recommend
at the bottom if you have anything that
you know really
stands out as a uni student so for me it
was
the carb scholarship recipient if you
have anything that you know for example
you did really well in the course came
top 10 or
you went on exchange something like that
i would really recommend including that
as a key highlight under your university
experiences
alright so moving on to the work
experience section you can see that i
followed a certain structure when
writing down each of my experiences
i started off with the role followed by
the company
the location and then i had a few
sentences describing what i was able to
achieve
so having a structure like this really
helps you concisely showcase the value
you can bring to a company
and one thing i wanted to mention is
that you don't necessarily have to put
in every single experience you've had
since you started working
and to be honest it's not really
recommended because you really want to
be tethering your resume
to the specific job that you're applying
for and looking at the type of skills
that they prefer in candidates
and i know for some of you you might be
applying for your first ever internship
so your previous experiences
might not have been in a corporate
setting you might have been a sales
assistant
worked in retail or did some high school
tutoring but really think about the
transferable skills that you can bring
from those roles into your future role
and the best way to showcase that would
be
through dot points under your job title
i would recommend starting off each stop
point with a verb so
what did you do did you teach did you
support
did you help implement did you lead
really have to think about what you
ended up doing in the role
the second thing i wanted to mention is
to try to quantify your impact
sometimes it's really tempting to just
say i taught some students
javascript but it's really important to
not only quantify
how many students you taught so for in
my case
it was classes of up to 30 students but
also what sort of impact i created so
in my example it was i received an
average 4.9 rating
from over 50 students so really reflect
on your past experiences
and try and dig up any numbers that you
have to really showcase the impact that
you bring
the next section on my resume is
university experiences
and i will structure this the same way
as i structure my work experiences
because
there's the role the company or the
project that you're part of
and there's also the dot points stating
what you did and the impact that you had
so pretty much similar
the only sort of difference is that this
is the impact and experience that you
gain throughout your time in university
and with that being said one thing i
wanted to emphasize is that you should
only be putting experiences that you
feel comfortable and passionate talking
about during an interview
so you should be really familiar and
confident with talking about each of the
dot points
with your experiences and the experience
itself so in my case i had to think
about which experiences really brought
upon the biggest impact for me
personally
and also in terms of the skills i was
able to build during my time at
university
one thing i just realized is that i
don't have dates
on any of the unique experiences on the
right
so i would recommend keeping it
consistent making sure that every
experience on your resume has a certain
date attached to it just to keep it
consistent for formatting
so the uni experience that i was really
passionate about is doing the same
digital society and co-founding that
with a bunch of friends so
that definitely went on to the top of my
uni experience list
that way it not only stands out on the
resume but also going into the interview
phase when interviewers look at your
resume they're more likely to point out
that experience and ask you to elaborate
on it
so a lot of the time the interviewer
would already have your resume on hand
when they interview you
so that they can ask you questions
related to experience so yeah i guess
that's sort of a benefit when it comes
to having resumes that are one page long
it's really condensed and you can sort
of pick and choose experiences that you
feel passionately talking about
and you feel like will bring the most
value okay so the last two sections that
i have on my resume are competitions and
skills and knowledge areas
and i would argue that these two are
pretty much optional
if you have space on your resume you
could put that in and if you don't i
would say just leave it out
in my case i decided to put competitions
in because i thought it was really a key
part in my uni experience
it really helped me develop the
confidence in solving problems and also
public speaking so that's something i
put in as a highlight and also because i
just had a bit of space at the end
in terms of skills and knowledge areas i
really feel like this is something you
can probably integrate with the rest of
your resume so
you can put that into the work
experience and university experiences
for example in my resume i said i had
skills in html css and javascript
but if you look above i actually already
mentioned that in one of my experiences
so i think if you don't have enough
space in your resume it's something that
you can really leave out
i guess one advantage of this is that
you can help recruiters quickly identify
what skills you have
but other than that i don't think it's
something that is really necessary to
put on the resume
so one more thing to flag before i wrap
this video up is that my resume was for
a non-technical role so if you're
applying for a technical role i guess
there'll be some differences in that
you'll probably have to showcase your
technical projects
so i guess that's just something to keep
in mind and that was the resume that got
me
into amazon but to be honest people can
fall into the trap that the resume is
everything you need and you have to
really perfect your resume
make sure that every single word is
right but there's so many components to
getting an offer
and the resume is only the very first
step there's so many other things you
can do
such as building a network on linkedin
connecting with people
really figuring out what the company
values what the role entails
so i guess just make sure you spread
your time out evenly spend a few hours
on your resume but really make sure that
you don't dwell on it too much
so yeah i hope you found this video
insightful and if you have any questions
feel free to leave it down in the
comments below
make sure you give this video a like and
subscribe to this channel to stay
updated bye for now